- Uh-oh! Sam Bankman-Fried
is now Sam Bankman-Felon.
Yeah, this was apparently
news to Bankman-Fried.
He was scheduled to testify
in front of Congress
on December 13th, and
just 24 hours earlier
while playing video games
in his Bahamas penthouse,
he told interviewers that he would have
to attend the hearing by Zoom
because he was quite overbooked.
He also remarked, "I don't
think I will be arrested."
And maybe when he said overbooked,
he meant "about to be booked,"
because later that same day,
authorities arrested Bankman-Fried,
took him into custody,
and prepared to extradite
him to the United States,
where he's been indicted for
wire fraud, securities fraud,
commodities fraud, money laundering,
and illegal campaign contributions.
Classic Pisces.
And now we know that most
of the C-Suite at FTX,
including Bankman-Fried's confidantes,
have reached plea agreements
with the government
and are cooperating with the government
against Sam Bankman-Fried.
And this helps explain how
things moved so quickly.
And as we discussed in our last video,
it looked like there was going
to be a jurisdictional tussle
between regulators who would win the right
to prosecute Bankman-Fried.
Now we know the regulators decided
that there was enough crimeing
and torting to go around
for everyone, with civil
complaints being filed
by the Securities Exchange
Commission, the SEC,
and the Commodities Futures
Trading Commission, the CFTC,
as well as criminal charges
by the Department of Justice.
Fortunately for Bankman-Fried,
he's used to living with tons of roommates
and wearing the same clothes every day.
(funky music)
Now, before we get into
all of the alleged crimes,
and there are a lot of alleged crimes,
let's do a quick factual rundown
because now we have the benefit
of three detailed proceedings,
two civil complaints,
and one criminal DOJ indictment.
Now, the SEC and the CFTC
filed separate civil complaints
providing additional factual context
to what is alleged to have gone on here.
Now, as you probably know,
Bankman-Fried was the
founder of Alameda Research,
which he represented as a separate entity
from the FTX entities,
especially after Caroline Ellison
and Sam Trabucco became
co-CEOs of Alameda in 2021.
However, the SEC and CFTC say
that Bankman-Fried did not hand
off Alameda Research at all
and that he remained the ultimate
decision-maker at Alameda.
The SEC says that Bankman-Fried
directed investment
and operational decisions,
frequently communicated
with Alameda employees,
and had full access to
Alameda's records and databases,
and the CFTC says that
Bankman-Fried operated all
of these entities as a common enterprise,
which is no surprise given the allegations
that we've seen in the news
where basically they were
commingling all of these funds.
So in other words, FTX, Alameda,
and many of their related
businesses were all run
by Bankman-Fried and Alameda
without any corporate controls
or separation that Bankman-Fried promised.
The CFTC said that all of
this was baked into the cake.
Quote: "FTX trading executives
also created other exceptions
to FTX's standard processes
that allowed Alameda
to have an unfair
advantage when transacting
on the platform, including
quicker execution times
and an exemption from the
platform's distinctive
auto-liquidation risk management process."
Now, all of this started
coming out in November.
You can check out my earlier
video on how this came to be.
In December, just before
Bankman-Fried was going
to testify in Congress, he was arrested
in the Bahamas, where he lives.
The US Attorney's Office
for the Southern District
of New York presented
evidence to a grand jury,
the grand jury indicted him,
and then the US Attorney's
Office made provisional requests
for his arrest with the Bahamas.
The US has an extradition
treaty with the Bahamas,
and that extradition
treaty will take a while,
but eventually he will be transferred
to the custody of the
American authorities.
That means that Bankman-Fried
faces a three-headed monster
because the SEC and the CFTC's cases
will have broad discovery procedures,
which will force Bankman-Fried
to turn over documents.
He'll have to give a deposition testimony,
which could incriminate
him in the criminal case,
and his lawyers will
probably ask the court
to stay the civil cases while
he defends the criminal case.
The judge has the discretion
to decide whether to grant that motion,
though don't be surprised
if Bankman-Fried ends up
taking the Fifth on a lot of this stuff,
though in the civil proceedings,
taking the Fifth can be used against you
and adverse inferences can be drawn
by your assertion of the Fifth Amendment,
though the SEC has more
power than the criminal court
to immediately freeze
actions by the entities
that are under the Alameda/FTX banner.
And the plea agreements from
Sam Bankman-Fried's compatriots
paint a damning picture.
Former Alameda Research
CEO Caroline Ellison
and FTX co-founder Gary
Wang have now pleaded guilty
to federal fraud charges
and are cooperating
with the Justice
Department's investigation.
- I wanna make two announcements.
First, I'm announcing
that the Southern District
of New York has filed charges
against Caroline Ellison,
the former CEO of Alameda
Research, and Gary Wang,
a co-founder of FTX, in
connection with their roles
in the frauds that
contributed to FTX's collapse.
Both Ms. Ellison and Mr. Wang
have pled guilty to those charges.
- The Justice Department
made the announcement
on December 22nd, the same day
that Bankman-Fried waived
extradition to the US.
Bankman-Fried is now out of jail
and back in his mom's
basement as a result.
The federal court set bail at $250 million
and Bankman-Fried was bonded out.
Now, a bail bond is usually about 10%
of the total bail amount, so
he probably had to come up
with around $25 million in assets.
The court record shows
that his parents will need
to post equity interest in their home
by January 12th, 2023,
and this comes just weeks
after Bankman-Fried told
George Stephanopoulos
that he only had about $100,000
left in his bank account.
Now, the bail disposition said
that two non-parent charities
would also sign bonds for lesser amounts.
The terms of the release
require Bankman-Fried
to surrender his passport,
and he'll be confined
to detention at his parents'
home in Palo Alto, California,
where he will have to
wear an ankle monitor.
Bankman-Fried's parents co-sign the bond
and Bankman-Fried is barred
from starting a business
or operating new lines of
credit more than $1,000
unless approved by the
government or the court.
The court records show that he'll need
to undergo a mental health evaluation
and may request to leave
the house for exercise.
Now, Caroline Ellison's
unsigned plea agreement says
that she admitted to seven counts,
including committing wire
fraud on FTX customers
and lenders of Alameda Research,
conspiracy to commit commodities
fraud and securities fraud,
and conspiracy to commit money laundering.
Now, the maximum sentence of incarceration
on those counts is 110 years,
but she's not gonna
face anything like that,
especially because she's cooperating.
But Ellison must continue to cooperate
or else she could be
charged with other crimes.
Ellison also agreed to
the forfeiture charge,
and the government says
that it cannot agree
not to prosecute her for tax fraud
if those charges are appropriate.
By pleading guilty,
Ellison is not guaranteed
a lighter sentence,
but typically, defendants
who cooperate completely
do get a lighter sentence,
and the plea agreements
also require her to make restitution.
Ellison was released on bail
but cannot leave the country.
Wang pleaded guilty to
four counts of wire fraud
and conspiracy to commit wire fraud,
commodities fraud, and securities fraud.
The maximum sentence for those crimes
is about 50 years in prison.
Wang also agreed to
restitution to his victims
and agreed to the forfeiture.
Now, the same cooperation
terms apply to Wang,
but he was also released
on bail with a condition
that he not leave the country.
Both plea agreements included
sections that are redacted
so as not to tip off
Bankman-Fried and other targets
about specific information that Ellison
and Wang shared with investigators.
And in separate actions,
the SEC charged Wang and
Ellison with securities fraud,
and the CFTC also filed fraud charges
against Ellison and Wang.
The CFTC'S amended complaint
against Bankman-Fried
adds charges against
Ellison and Wang for fraud
in material representations
in connection with the sale
of digital asset commodities
in interstate commerce,
and the CFTC hit Wang for
creating the code features
in the FTX trading platform
that allowed Alameda
to have an unlimited credit line on FTX
without being detected.
And the CFTC complaint offers more details
about what happened in
November when crypto declined
and FTX could not keep up
with customer withdrawals.
Publicly, Bankman-Fried claimed
that there was just a liquidity
problem while privately,
quote, "Bankman-Fried, Ellison,
and other key personnel
at FTX and Alameda acknowledged internally
that this shortfall
was not merely a matter
of having sufficient liquid assets on hand
to cover customer withdrawals
in the short term.
Rather, FTX customer assets
were irrevocably lost
because Alameda had misappropriated them."
The CFTC says that Bankman-Fried's
infamous tweet threads
of November 6th and 7th,
the ones where he apologized
for being a screw-up and accused Binance
of trying to sabotage FTX,
were workshopped ahead
of time with Ellison,
Wang, and other advisors.
The CFTC says, quote,
"several individuals expressed concerns
that Bankman-Fried's tweet was inaccurate
and/or misleading."
And on November 9th,
after Binance announced
that it would acquire FTX in its entirety,
Ellison held an all-hands meeting
with employees of Alameda Research.
During the meeting, she
provided detailed information
about the years-long fraud.
Quote: "Ellison stated
that 'starting last year,'
Alameda was 'borrowing a bunch
of money by open term loans'
and used those assets to 'make
very illiquid investments.'
Ellison further explained that following
the widespread decline
of digital asset prices,
most of Alameda's loans had been recalled
and, in order to meet those recalls,
Alameda borrowed 'a
bunch of funds' from FTX,
which in turn 'led to FTX having
a shortfall in user funds.'
Ellison informed Alameda staff
that FTX had 'always allowed' Alameda
to borrow customer assets
and did not require
collateral for those loans.
She also explained that Alameda
could access user assets
without requiring FTX's approval
as the 'structure' allowed Alameda
to 'go negative in coins.'
In response to an employee question,
Ellison also acknowledged
that her November 6th tweet
to the Binance CEO offering
to buy his FTT holdings
at $22 per token was 'kind of
a misleading thing to tweet'
and expressed remorse.
Shortly after this meeting,
most of Alameda's staff resigned."
So basically, Caroline
Ellison sort of admitted to,
you know, like, borrowing
a bunch of money from FTX,
being allowed to have,
like, a negative balance,
and that FTX and Alameda
just kept moving stuff around
until the bottom dropped
out of the market,
and then, you know, what do you know,
there's nothing left to borrow
when the customers couldn't
withdraw their money.
Classic Pisces.
One day later,
FTX and 133 related entities
filed for bankruptcy.
- I declare bankruptcy!
- It was all you know, very
cool, very progressive,
very edgy until, you know, it wasn't.
Ellison and Wang do not
contest their liability
to the CFTC's claims, and
their testimony makes it
very hard for Bankman-Fried to claim
that he didn't know what he was doing
and aw, shucks, it was
just a big old mistake.
Wang and Ellison also agreed to the entry
of consent orders of judgment
as to their liability
for engaging in massive fraud.
The SEC complaint against Wang
and Ellison gives us more clues
about how they were cooperating
against Bankman-Fried.
With respect to the fiat@ftx.com account,
the SEC said that some of
the bank accounts, quote,
"were not in Alameda's
name but rather the name
of North Dimension Inc.,
an Alameda subsidiary.
North Dimension's website does
not disclose any connection
to Alameda," but apparently, "Ellison knew
that Bankman-Fried had directed FTX
to have customers send
funds to North Dimension
in an effort to hide the fact
that the funds were being sent
to an account controlled by Alameda."
Apparently, Alameda didn't
segregate those customer funds
and the North Dimension account
is actually the multibillion-dollar debt
referred to as the fiat@ftx.com account.
The fiat@ftx.com account
was then listed as a loan
on the quarterly balance
sheets, and Ellison allegedly
at Bankman-Fried's direction
combined this liability
with loans Alameda had received
from third-party lenders to obscure
Alameda's intertwined financial
relationship with FTX.
Now, this information, if true,
is fairly damning evidence
of the defendant's intent to
mislead and conceal information
from investors, lenders, and customers.
The complaint says, "In
2022, FTX started trying
to separate Alameda's debt
in the fiat@ftx.com account
from the portion attributable to FTX."
And when Alameda's portion was moved
to a different account,
it triggered a process
that added interest to Alameda's debt.
Quote: "Bankman-Fried directed
that the Alameda liability
be moved to an account
that would not be charged with interest.
This account was associated
with an individual
that had no apparent
connection to Alameda.
As a result, this change had the effect
of further concealing Alameda's liability
in FTX's internal systems."
And when crypto started crashing in May,
causing Alameda's lenders to come calling,
Bankman-Fried told Ellison
to hide the unlimited line of
credit on the balance sheet
so that the lenders didn't know about it.
And Ellison admitted to making statements
that she knew were untrue.
For example, in a Bloomberg article
from September 2022,
"Bankman-Fried claimed
that 'Alameda is a wholly
separate entity' than FTX,"
and "in the same article,
Ellison is quoted
as stating about Alameda,
quote, 'We're at arm's length.
We don't get any different treatment
from other market makers."
And as for the technical issues,
Wang designed the so-called risk engine
that Bankman-Fried touted to investors.
The SEC complaint notes
that Bankman-Fried
touted this risk protocol
when he testified to Congress.
Quote: "There is a complete transparency
about the positions that are held.
There's a robust consistent
risk framework applied."
Of course, one of the biggest problems
is the risk engine didn't apply
to FTX's biggest customer,
Alameda Research.
Wang knew this because he was the person
who created the code
exempting Alameda Research
from the rules and that
Ellison was aware of
and took advantage of this
special undisclosed benefit.
Of course, this is just
scratching the surface.
There's additional juicy details
about Alameda propping
up the price of FTT,
FTX using bots to manipulate
the entire market,
and then the employees and
founders issuing giant loans
to each other at the company's expense.
Now, the SEC complaint alleges
that Bankman-Fried violated two parts
of the Securities Exchange Act of 1933,
breaching Section 17a and 10b.
Both of these sections prohibit
making false representations
to investors as opposed
to customers who would
be the exchange's users.
Now, the crux of the SEC's charges
are that Bankman-Fried
transferred billions of dollars
of FTX money to Alameda Research
while misleading FTX's investors
about FTX's financial
condition and risk management.
- At the end of the day, look,
there's a question of
what happened and why.
- Alameda used this money to cover loans
and make additional venture
investments and personal loans
to Bankman-Fried and
other FTX investments.
(funky music)
Even in November 2022, faced
with billions of dollars
in customer withdrawal demands
that FTX could not fulfill,
Bankman-Fried misled investors
about a multibillion-dollar hole.
Now, the SEC alleged that
Bankman-Fried committed fraud
in the offer or sale of securities
in violation of Section 17a.
The section makes it illegal
to mislead investors.
Specifically, it says it's
unlawful to employ any device,
scheme, or artifice to defraud,
obtain money or property
by using material
misstatements or emissions,
or to engage in any transaction practice
or course of business which
operates or would operate
as a fraud or deceit upon the purchaser.
Now, the SEC typically
relies more on Rule 10b-5
for its enforcement
actions but in recent years
has stepped up prosecutions
under 17a, in part
because of the regulation's
weaker scienter requirements.
Now, scienter is another
word for the mental intent,
the knowledge of wrongdoing.
And when the SEC brings a
civil case, as it did here,
a violation of Section
17a can be established
if the defendant acted negligently,
in contrast to civil violation
of Rule 10b-5 requires
that the defendant must have
acted at least recklessly,
which is a higher mental
state than just negligence.
The SEC says that
Bankman-Fried allowed Alameda
to have a negative balance on its account
without any collateral requirements
and gave Alameda unlimited
access to credit.
No other account had these privileges,
and they were accomplished
by writing Alameda-specific bypasses
in the FTX codebase in August 2019.
Alameda's collateral was also allowed
to fall below the requisite margin levels
without triggering the automatic
liquidation of its account.
And while Bankman-Fried pulled strings
to give Alameda these special privileges,
he did not disclose any
of them to FTX investors,
though news reports also suggest
that investors did not do
proper due diligence in FTX,
but perhaps that was partly
because Bankman-Fried
did not give the investors
much information to work with,
telling them to look at the
terms of service and pointing
to a document called FTX's
Key Principles for Ensuring
Investor Protections on
Digital-Asset Platforms,
in which FTX claimed that it, quote,
"segregates customer assets
from its own assets across our platforms."
The SEC says FTX provided this document
to potential investors, quote,
"including a US investor
who invested $35 million
in FTX's Series B fundraising
round in July 2021."
But these statements were false,
as FTX did not segregate customer
assets from its own assets
and, as events would later demonstrate,
did not maintain liquidity
to allow customer withdrawals on demand.
Now, FTX did provide audited financials,
but those statements
don't include information
about Alameda's
undocumented line of credit
from FTX or the other information
about its special deals with Alameda.
Bankman-Fried told investors
that Alameda did not get
any special treatment
and that he told his
executives to emphasize
that FTX and Alameda were
two separate entities.
The SEC says that all of that
was materially misleading,
and that seems kind of
like a slam-dunk case.
Now, the SEC also alleges
that Bankman-Fried violated Section 10b-5,
the more traditional fraud provisions
that are used in a situation like this.
The SEC alleges that Bankman-Fried
used creative accounting
and little documentation
to hide his personal loans.
According to the complaint, quote,
"between March 2020 and September 2022,
Bankman-Fried executed
promissory notes for loans
from Alameda totaling
more than $1.338 billion,
including two instances
in which Bankman-Fried
was both the borrower
in his individual capacity and the lender
in his capacity as CEO of Alameda."
Bankman-Fried used these loans
to make political contributions
and buy real estate
for himself, his parents,
and other FTX executives,
and besides all of this,
the SEC alleges that, quote,
"the record keeping regarding
the purchase and ownership
of real estate was poorly
organized and documented.
Neither the fact of the
loans and the purchases
nor the poor documentation
of significant company liabilities
and expenditures was
disclosed to investors."
- So you do know and you did know
that FDX deposits were
being funneled to Alameda.
- So I was vaguely aware that that was how
some wires were being
sent in the first place.
- Now, I'm sensing a theme here.
Now, the SEC also cites
a September 2022 meeting
for US investors in which FTX claimed,
quote, "outside of BlockFi,
we didn't increase our
exposure to crypto."
That statement was, quote,
"false and misleading."
Bankman-Fried knew that as a result,
"FTX's exposure to crypto,
including its own FTT token,
increased substantially as
Alameda increased its borrowing,
backed by FTT as collateral."
Now, the CFTC lawsuit is a
civil enforcement action,
which means that it isn't
charging Bankman-Fried criminally.
That's what the DOJ is doing.
But the complaint seeks disgorgement,
i.e., paying back of all
the ill-gotten gains,
civil penalties, a ban
on Bankman-Fried acting
as an officer or director of a company,
and to prohibit him from
participating in the issuance,
purchase, offer, or sale of
any securities in the future.
Now, that takes us to the CFTC complaint.
Now, I told you before
that the CFTC believed
that it had the authority to
regulate crypto as a commodity,
and its complaint against Bankman-Fried
and FTX makes no bones about it.
Quote: "Certain digital
assets are commodities,
including bitcoin, ether,
tether, and others,
as defined under the
Commodity Exchange Act."
Thus, the agency filed a
complaint naming Bankman-Fried,
FTX Trading Ltd., and Elevated
Research LLC as defendants.
Much of the CFTC'S
complaint reiterates facts
let out concurrently
in the SEC's complaint,
including all the stuff
about the special treatment
of Alameda Research that it
got from FTX and the fact
that Alameda Research served
as a limitless slush fund
for Bankman-Fried and
other FTX executives.
In fact, the CFTC says that
these built-in advantages
for Alameda, quote, "directly
contradicted public statements
made by and on behalf of defendants."
This allowed Alameda to use FTX assets
whenever it needed to
pay off its own lenders.
The CFTC says that FTX also
made a giant no-interest loan
to Alameda, which it concealed
with the now-infamous line item
on the balance sheet called fiat@.
Quote: "During the relevant period,
this account held a balance of as much
as $8 billion in customer funds."
Now, that wasn't the only time
that Bankman-Fried used a weird trick
your accountant doesn't
want you to know about
to hide an enormous liability.
Quote: "At least in part
to remediate the risk
that Alameda's large
liability would be discovered,
at Bankman-Fried's
discretion, FTX executives
reallocated Alameda's
approximately $1 billion
in liabilities to a customer
account on FTX's system
that Bankman-Fried would later refer to
as 'our Korean friend's account'
and/or 'the weird Korean account.'
This was technically a
sub-account of Alameda,
but unlike other Alameda
sub-accounts on FTX,
it was not opened under a
@alamedaresearch.com identifier
and was not otherwise readily identifiable
as being an Alameda-associated account."
This, in plain terms, seems like fraud.
The CFTC charged Bankman-Fried
with violating Section 6c
of the Commodities Exchange Act,
which is basically a
pattern after Rule 10b
of the Securities and Exchange Act.
The law is a broad sort
of catch-all provision
that prohibits fraud in all of its forms,
and the law prohibits
manipulative and deceptive devices
and contrivances in connection
with any swap or contract,
basically anything in relation
to the sale of a commodity.
Now, the newest amendments
to the law were added in 2010
by the Dodd-Frank Act,
which make it easier
for the CFTC to charge fraud
because the government
no longer has to prove
that a defendant specifically intended
to create a price trend
that was manipulative.
Now, the CFTC can charge
anyone who uses manipulative
or deceptive devices as
intentionally reckless in conduct
that's intended to create or
did create an artificial price.
Now, that takes us to
the criminal indictment
from the Department of Justice.
The US Attorney's Office
for the Southern District
of New York, which handles
a lot of financial crimes
because New York City is
within the Southern District
of New York, and they
obtained an indictment
against Bankman-Fried for
conspiracy to commit wire fraud,
wire fraud conspiracy to
commit commodities fraud,
conspiracy to commit securities fraud,
conspiracy to commit money laundering,
and conspiracy to defraud the
Federal Election Commission
and commit campaign finance violations.
Now, we kicked off our first
video about Bankman-Fried
by discussing the
possibility of wire fraud,
and what do you know?
It was wire fraud.
Wire fraud specifically involves the use
of telecommunications or
online communications,
including emails, social
media, text messages,
or even good old-fashioned fax machines.
The unsealed indictment
says that starting in 2019
and continuing until November of 2022,
Bankman-Fried committed wire fraud.
Now, this might not have
come as a complete shock
to Bankman-Fried, because according
to the Australian
website Financial Review,
Bankman-Fried and his FTX
and Alameda associates
had a secret chat group
called, cryptically, Wirefraud.
The group exchanged
secret messages on Signal
about the potential for US wire
fraud charges for their role
in the implosion of FTX
and Alameda Research.
In response to the allegation,
Bankman-Fried tweeted, "If this is true,
then I wasn't a member
of that inner circle.
I'm quite sure it's just false.
I have never heard of such a group."
Though, on the other
hand, maybe he just wanted
to save the Department of
Justice a whole bunch of money
in making it super easy to prosecute him
and everyone that he worked with.
And as I mentioned,
the government also criminally
charged Bankman-Fried
with various species of
conspiracy to commit wire fraud,
securities fraud, commodities fraud,
money laundering, and
campaign finance violations,
and regarding that last
charge, the prosecutor said
that Bankman-Fried misappropriated tens
of millions of dollars of customer funds
to make illegal donations
to both Democratic
and Republican candidates.
So the question is, if
Bankman-Fried is convicted,
how long is he going to jail?
Well, the CFTC and the
SEC filed civil complaints
seeking monetary damages
and injunctive relief
to prevent Bankman-Fried
from being near a corporation
or a company ever again.
Now, the fines could be
enormous in this case,
but it'll probably take
a long time to resolve
with potentially years of discovery
and a string of bankruptcies
to sort things through.
The criminal case filed by the Department
of Justice will go much faster.
Now, Bankman-Fried was
indicted for a number
of different federal felonies,
some of which meld into each other,
but some are separate counts.
And unlike the CFTC
and the SEC complaints,
if the DOJ convicts, Sam
Bankman-Fried could be looking
at a long sentence.
The amount of time he gets
depends on two things:
the offenses of conviction
and the federal sentencing guidelines.
The sentencing guidelines
provide 43 levels
of offense seriousness.
The more serious the crime,
the higher the offense level,
and each type of crime is
assigned a base offense level,
which is the starting point
for determining the seriousness
of the particular offense.
Now, Bankman-Fried is
not a prior offender,
which would normally reduce the sentence,
but the nature of his crimes is serious,
and there are at least
three different groups
of victims here: lenders, customers,
and the United States government.
Now, wire fraud carries
a maximum prison sentence
of up to 20 years, and if
the wire fraud involves
over $550 million, which is
possible if not likely here,
then Bankman-Fried could
get a maximum sentence,
even without a prior criminal history.
Securities fraud carries
a maximum sentence
of up to 25 years in prison and a fine
that is based on the amount of money
that was fraudulently
obtained, which here was a lot,
and a conviction for money
laundering could result
in a sentence of up to
20 years and a big fine.
So if we look at it conservatively,
assuming the government proves some
but not all of the charges,
Bankman-Fried could get a
sentence of 10 to 15 years.
There's still a lot of
things that we don't know
since the case is still
in its very early stages,
and it could be a lot more than that.
Now, maybe the strangest
story related to SBF's arrest
is that his family
reportedly called the prison
to request vegan meals.
Now, that's not going to happen.
But he could get a delicious vegan meal
from today's sponsor,
Factor, or a keto meal
or a high-protein meal
or a calorie-smart meal
because Factor makes meeting
your nutrition goals easier
than ever by delivering
fresh, never-frozen,
dietician-approved meals
right to your doorstep,
unless you're Sam Bankman-Fried.
And the meals are completely ready to eat.
Their team of gourmet
chefs creates each meal
using only ingredients with integrity
to help you feel your best all day long.
Factor supports wholesome
eating made simple.
Their menus are updated weekly.
It includes over 27 meals and 33 add-ons.
You can choose your favorite meals
or let Factor craft your order
based on your taste
preferences and meal history.
Factor takes the guesswork
out of grocery shopping
and meal prep, saving you time
and energy for other things.
Factor's no-hassle
prepared foods make sure
that you always have
something nutritious on hand
when you don't have time to
think about making a meal.
And sometimes I just want a delicious,
healthy meal without having to cook,
and Factor's meals arrive pre-packaged
and ready to eat in just two minutes.
Meal plans range from
4 to 18 meals per week,
so I can always scale up my
meals if I need the extra energy
for a long day of lawyering.
And Factor is now owned by HelloFresh,
so there's a wider array of
meal plans to choose from.
There's something for everyone,
whether you want to cook it yourself
or have a meal ready to go.
So give Factor a try by going
to go.factor.75.com/LEGALEAGLE60
and use the code LEGALEAGLE60
to get 60% off your first Factor boxes,
or just click on the link
that's onscreen right now
or down in the description
and use the code LEGALEAGLE60
to get 60% off across six boxes.
After that, click on this box over here
for more Legal Eagle, or
I'll see you in court.